Good afternoon.
Thank you very much,
indeed, for coming.
So my task this
afternoon is to take you
on a bit of a tour
of the solar system.
For reasons of time, I
have had to limit myself
to planets and dwarf planets.
If you have a particular
enthusiasm for moons,
I'm afraid I won't be
talking about those,
but you're welcome to
ask questions at the end.
One of the joyous things
about being an astronomer,
just at the moment, is
that virtually everything
that I'm going to tell
you this afternoon
has been discovered
within our lifetimes.
In the Space Age, we've
had the opportunity
to send spacecraft out to
explore the solar system.
We've learnt an enormous
amount about what's out there.
We've also discovered
a whole load of things
that we're not quite
so clear about,
so we've created a few
mysteries for ourselves as well.
And what I'll hopefully
do, as I go through this,
is highlight some of the things
that we still don't understand
about our local neighbourhood.
So I'm going to
start with Mercury
and work my way out
towards the edge
of the solar system in
the hope of giving it
some sort of structure.
And this is the first mission
that was sent to Mercury.
It was a NASA mission
and called Mariner 10.
It's an example of how
back in the mid-1970s
we didn't understand quite
the environment that we
were dealing with.
So no sophisticated onboard
computers on this spacecraft.
So it had to rely,
for navigation,
on a star tracker, which was
basically a telescope that
was designed to take
an image of the heavens
around the spacecraft and
find the star Canopus, which
is bright, and lock onto it.
And then use that as a
way of navigating its way
towards the planet Mercury.
Now, one of the things
NASA were concerned about
was they were going
towards Mercury--
that was close to the sun.
They were a little concerned
that the spacecraft would
get quite hot, so
they provided it
with a sun shield which
they thought would
keep the electronics cool.
That was a good idea.
They then said to
themselves, well,
we're going to send radio
signals up a wave guide
to this antenna to beam the
pictures that we take back
to the Earth.
Perhaps it would be a good
idea if we painted that wave
guide white, so that it would
reflect the sun's energy
and not get too hot.
That was an example of
how they didn't really
understand the effects
of the space environment
on paint, back then.
We don't paint things that
we send into space anymore,
because paint really doesn't
enjoy the space environment.
It tends to flake off.
Now, you can see what
potentially happens here.
The paint flakes
off the wave guide
and then starts drifting
along beside the spacecraft.
And eventually, a paint
flake drifts into the field
of view of the star camera.
Now, it's very small, but
it's very close to the camera
and it's reflecting sunlight.
So the camera, which is
designed to find the brightest
thing in its field, say, oh,
and starts to track the paint
flakes instead of
the star Canopus,
which was a bit of a problem.
Eventually, NASA realised
what the problem was,
and then they made a random
manoeuvre to leave the cloud
of paint flakes behind.
And eventually,
they got to Mercury.
And what they found
when they got there,
as you can see the picture
on the right-hand side,
is a very ancient surface.
There are thousands and
thousands of craters
on the surface of Mercury,
implying that it's
a very ancient surface.
There has been a long
time for a lot of impacts
to happen on the
surface of Mercury.
And I'll return to
that sort of theme
again later in the presentation.
The number of craters you
count are a good indication
of the age of a surface.
So we discovered a few
things about Mercury
that we didn't expect.
We found that it has
a magnetic field.
I don't think many people
thought that Mercury would
still have some
sort of liquid core
that was actually allowing it
to generate a magnetic field.
We found an enormous
impact feature,
called the Caloris Basin.
And that's quite an
interesting feature,
because what we
think happened was
there was a massive impact
that created that crater,
and the shockwaves ran
around the edge of Mercury
until they met up again on
the far side, at which point
there was nowhere
for the energy to go.
And the energy, basically,
just completely disturbed
the surface of Mercury, to
the point where, essentially,
the geologists just
gave up and decided
to call it Weird Terrain.
Now.
I'll just throw out one
slight point to ponder.
Does that same process
happen on the Earth?
65 million years ago there
was a very large impact
that is supposed to have
killed off the dinosaurs.
That happened in the
Yucatan Peninsula.
So where's the opposite
point on the Earth?
Well, it turns out, that's
somewhere in the Indian Ocean.
A bit south of where India is
today, but almost exactly where
India was 65 million years ago.
And if you know
your geology, you'll
know there's a thing called
the Deccan Traps, which
are huge outpourings
of lava that covered
a large part of the
Indian subcontinent,
dated to about the same
age, and at the point where
India was 65 million years ago.
Maybe that process
happens here, too.
Now, a more recent
mission to Mercury
is called Messenger, and
that spacecraft another NASA
mission.
Rather more sophisticated
piece of kit,
with a much cleverer camera.
So we're now looking at taking
separate images in a number
of different
spectral bands, i.e.,
and a number of
different colour bands.
And what that allows you to do
is a much more sophisticated
estimate of what the
different materials are
on the surface of Mercury.
So some of them are thought
to be impact features.
Some of them are thought to be
sort of volcanic type features
where material came out of
the interior of Mercury.
And some of the areas--
the stuff marked in
blue on this picture--
are still giving the
geologists pause for thought.
When we figure it out,
we'll let you know.
Now, one of the
things that I find
fascinating about these images
from the Messenger spacecraft
is that there are evidence
of, what I'm going to call,
volatiles on the surface.
So volatiles-- things like
water, maybe carbon dioxide,
anything that will turn into
a gas when it warms up--
you would have
thought that Mercury,
being relatively
close to the sun,
would have lost any of that
sort of material a long time ago
and would be completely
depleted in volatiles.
But the light-coloured
deposits on the surface
that you can see here
are very recent deposits.
We can tell that
because those deposits
lie over the tops of the
various impact features.
So they must have
been put there later.
So geologically
speaking, they're recent.
And the best hypothesis
for what's going on there
is that when Mercury was formed,
it was a molten ball of iron,
to a first
approximation, and there
was the ability for that iron
to accommodate a certain amount
of hydrogen gas.
And that over geological time,
as Mercury is very slowly
cooling down, the iron
can't hold onto as much
of that hydrogen.
And so very slowly,
Mercury is kind of fizzing
hydrogen into the space
environment, and
bringing with it whatever
that light-coloured deposit is.
At least we think
that's what's going on,
but that's another mystery
that we have to solve.
We don't have a good idea at
the moment of exactly what
those deposits are made of.
So moving on to Venus.
So if you try observing
Venus visually--
it's a very challenging
target, extraordinarily thick
atmosphere.
It's about 90 times the
Earth's atmospheric pressure.
And the temperature
is enormous as well.
You're looking at 480 degrees
C, I think, on average.
So it's not a very
pleasant place to go.
Most of the atmosphere
is carbon dioxide.
And as you can see, from
that picture on the screen,
you can't see through the
atmosphere in the visible part
of the spectrum.
That didn't deter the Russians.
So the Russians were the
first nation, and still
the only nation, to
ever land a spacecraft
on the surface of Venus.
A tricky thing to do, given
the pressure and temperature.
You'll notice that
the spacecraft looks
a bit like a pressure vessel.
It's got a degree of
spherical symmetry.
A lot of the early Russian
spacecraft were like that.
If you picture Sputnik,
it was also a ball.
It was designed to be
pressurised inside so that
the electronics had a relatively
benign environment to work in.
And that spacecraft managed
to get down to the surface,
and it took the only
pictures that we
have of the surface of Venus.
The version at the
top of this slide
is the picture that was put out
by the Russians at the time.
They were very proud
of the fact that they'd
managed to beat the Americans
to land on the surface of Venus.
The picture at the bottom is a
more recently processed version
of the same image, where they've
corrected for the colour change
that is involved with the light
coming down through that very
thick atmosphere.
It's not very pleasant
on the surface of Venus.
But it's also not that
funny mustardy-yellow colour
in reality.
And the bottom
picture shows what
it would look like if you
didn't have the atmospheric haze
to deal with.
The US have been to Venus.
They haven't actually
landed on the surface.
But what they did do was put
a spacecraft called Magellan
in orbit around it.
That spacecraft was deployed
by the space shuttle,
and had a radar
shown here, that was
able to send radio waves
down to the surface,
bounce the radio waves off the
surface and receive the echoes.
And essentially, was the sort of
satellite equivalent of a bat,
so it was able to do radar
imaging of the surface.
And if you do that,
you can essentially
remove the clouds from Venus,
which is what this image shows.
So interesting surface.
There aren't very many
impact craters on Venus.
Now, part of the reason
for that is that there's
a very thick atmosphere.
But the biggest impactors
potentially would still
go straight through.
So what that tells you,
the lack of craters,
is that Venus has a
relatively young surface.
And interestingly, the
surface looks pretty much
the same the whole planet over.
And we think that about 500
million years ago, there
was some resurfacing
event on Venus.
Maybe there was a
major impact that
dumped an enormous amount
of energy into Venus
and melted the whole
of the surface.
We're not quite sure.
But whatever it was, all
of the surface of Venus
is only 500 million
years old, compared
to a solar system lifetime of
about 4 and 1/2 billion years.
One of the other
things that we've
discovered from imaging
Venus in this way
is that there is evidence
of vulcanism everywhere.
What's interesting
about these features
is they're somewhat
reminiscent of the sort
of volcanic features that
you would see on Earth, but
much, much bigger.
So this is tens of
kilometres long.
It's an outflow from a volcano.
The reason it's so much
bigger than the outflows
from volcanoes on the
Earth, despite the fact
that Venus is a similar sized
body to the Earth, and it's
similar gravity, is that the
temperature is so much higher
that the rocks are
much less viscous,
and the lava, essentially,
flows more like water
than the sort of lava we're
familiar with on the surface
of the Earth.
Now, we haven't
necessarily caught
Venus in the process of
having a volcanic eruption.
It's a little tricky to do with
all that atmosphere in the way.
The European Space
Agency has sent a mission
and put it in orbit
around Venus as well.
That mission had
an infrared camera,
which was able to look
in the heat bands,
and they found some
things that look
rather like volcanoes which
appear to be hot at the top.
So that's a pretty
good indication
that they genuinely
are volcanoes and could
erupt at some point.
And there are some observations
such as this bright spot that
was seen in Venus's atmosphere.
So it's a transient feature.
It appeared for a while
in Earth-based telescopes
and then disappeared again.
And you wonder,
well, what was that?
Well, it's possible it was
a volcanic eruption down
on the surface, throwing a whole
load of different chemicals
into the atmosphere of Venus
at that particular location,
which interacted differently
with the sunlight,
and made Venus look a little
bit different in terms of colour
in that particular location.
But we still await the
first conclusive evidence
of a volcano actually
erupting on Venus.
One of the things that's
really puzzled the scientists
is the fact that in the gap
between the American Magellan
mission and the Venus
Express mission, the winds
and the rotation of Venus appear
to have changed significantly.
The winds have got a lot faster.
They've gone from, on average,
300 kilometres an hour
to 400 kilometres an hour.
And the rotation of Venus,
which is extremely slow,
appears to have
changed by about 6
and 1/2 minutes in the same
sort of period of time,
about 20 years, which is
really quite astonishing.
I mean, if you think
about the Earth,
it's about the same
size planet as Venus.
Our rotation changes almost
imperceptibly over that sort
of time.
You've probably heard
of us adding a leap
second occasionally.
That leap second is added
to account for the fact
that the Earth is very
slowly spinning down.
But it would appear that
Venus can change its rotation
rate by 6 and 1/2 minutes
in the same time, which
implies there's some really
weird and interesting
interaction going on
with its atmosphere
that we don't understand
at the moment.
So moving on to Mars--
I'm going to skip over the Earth
because we're already here.
So one of the first
major missions to Mars--
there were a few missions that
sort of flew past and took
images as they whizzed by.
But the first major
significant mission
was the one that
Carl Sagan, who was
mentioned in the introduction,
was much involved with.
So it was the Viking landers.
The lander's actually
inside this entry shroud,
so this part of the
spacecraft detached.
This bit stayed in orbit
to relay the pictures back
from this lander that's
folded up inside here.
And when they landed
they used this scoop
to dig a trench in the surface--
scoop up a bit of Martian soil--
and deploy it into, essentially,
a chemistry laboratory
on the lander.
And they attempted to spot
martian microbes in the soil.
They essentially
provided nutrients
that they thought
might feed a bacteria.
They saw a reaction inside
their chemistry lab.
There is still a
debate, even today,
about whether they
actually detected
some sort of microbial
life in the surface.
It's a very long debate.
I don't have time to
reiterate it all here.
But there are also some
very active chemicals
in the surface of Mars that
might also have created
the reaction that they saw.
So it's not entirely clear.
Also, bacteria are a
surprisingly stubborn things.
They can withstand
all sorts of exposure
to the space environment.
Although they tried to clean the
Viking spacecraft before they
sent them, it's possible
that there was still
some contamination from
some Earth bacteria
in the experiment somewhere.
And that when they actually
deposited the nutrients
in the Martian
soil, all they did
was feed some Earth bacteria
that they had taken with them.
And that debate continues now.
One of the reasons why I'm a
big fan of robotic exploration,
rather than manned
exploration, is
that there are so many
different places on Mars
that I would love
to send a robot to.
There are all sorts
of different terrain,
from polar caps, where you
can find water ice and carbon
dioxide ice.
There are all sorts of dunes
and sand-based features.
There's all sorts of really,
really interesting stuff
on Mars.
And this slide
just sort of shows
some of the variety
of different places
that you can go and visit.
So unlike Venus, which has
a very uniform surface,
Mars is very different.
Some of Mars' surface
is covered in craters,
implying it's quite old.
Some of the Northern hemisphere
of Mars has almost no craters,
and that's part of
the clue to the fact
that there may once have been
an ocean around the North
Pole of Mars.
We've managed with
European spacecraft,
a spacecraft called
Mars Express this time
rather than Venus Express,
to catch transient features
on the surface of Mars.
So these are avalanches.
We think they're created
by carbon dioxide frost.
As the seasons change
on Mars, just like there
are seasons on the Earth, the
temperature of the surface
heats up, and some of the
carbon dioxide, essentially,
warms up enough to
burst out of the surface
and create an avalanche, which
you can see in the pictures
here.
These are two
different avalanches.
And the fact that we've been
able to image more than one
of these very transient
events implies
that they're happening
relatively frequently.
The most comprehensive mission
that's been sent to the surface
so far is a mission
that's still working.
It was sent by NASA,
the Curiosity Rover.
Really complicated landing
sequence, involving parachutes
and heat shields initially.
And then there's this sort
of hovering deployment device
which winches down
the lander, which
is about the size of a
mini, onto the surface.
But now, within
our lifetimes we've
gone from the pictures
of Mars that we
had at the beginning
of the Space Age,
which were based on
Earth-based telescopes
where the pixel
resolution, if you like,
was hundreds of
kilometres across,
to being able to take close-up
pictures of rocks that
are really, really detailed.
I think that's just an
amazing leap forward
in terms of our understanding.
Now, one of the things that
that Rover was intended
to try and answer was,
was there ever liquid
water on the surface of Mars?
Lots of speculation about
whether there was or whether
there wasn't.
This first image from its
camera pretty much proves it.
So I hope you can see that
there's quite a lot of evidence
in these hills of layering.
So that's like sedimentary
layers on the Earth.
They are almost
certainly laid down
in the presence and
absence of water.
But the fact that
there are layers at all
is almost a dead
giveaway to a geologist
that there was definitely
water here once,
which is an
interesting situation,
as I'll explain in a moment.
That Rover, as I
mentioned, has been
able to take some very
close-up pictures, including
this thing, which looks
almost like a little flower.
Now, it's almost
certainly inorganic.
It's probably some
form of crystal growth.
Mars has a very,
very thin atmosphere,
so it's almost like growing
crystals in a vacuum.
We don't see the same conditions
on the Earth, obviously.
So exactly what that
is we're not sure,
because we don't see the
equivalent on the surface
of our own planet.
But the fact that it's there
at all is really interesting,
I think.
Now, what's got NASA
extremely excited
is the fact that, both from
their orbiting missions
and also from the rovers
down on the surface,
there's quite a
lot of evidence now
that there is methane in
the atmosphere of Mars.
Methane is produced
on the Earth, largely
either by volcanic activity
or by biological activity.
And we think that most of
the volcanic activity on Mars
stopped a very long time ago.
There are areas of volcanoes
on the surface of Mars.
In fact, the biggest
volcano in the solar system,
Mons Olympus is on Mars.
But we think all of
that volcanic activity
stopped a long time ago.
So the fact that we
see methane today,
and we see it in a sort
of seasonal fashion,
rather than sort of continuously
throughout the Martian year,
does sort of suggest
that it's seasonal
and that, just like
plants on the Earth
grow in the spring and summer
and then lose their leaves
in the winter and in
the autumn, that there
is seasonal activity, perhaps
in biologic activity, on Mars.
I had the good
fortune to have dinner
with Jim Green, who's the
Chief Scientist at NASA
a couple of weeks ago.
He wasn't exactly saying,
we found life on Mars.
But when asked, sort
of smiled and said,
"We find increasing
amounts of evidence."
And I think the situation
NASA finds itself in
is there's a lot of
scientists at NASA
who think they've got some
very compelling evidence
for essentially bacterial
sort of life forms on Mars.
And that an extraordinary
claim, "We found life on Mars,"
needs extraordinary
evidence to prove it.
So they're not going public yet.
I think they want to build
the case even further.
But there are some interesting
facts about this methane.
For example, the methane
disappears very quickly,
and that's a surprise.
You would expect the
methane to hang around
for some tens of years
before being broken down
by the ultraviolet light.
So if you find
methane for a while,
as part of some sort
of burst of activity,
and then it disappears
again, that sort of
implies that there's something
eating the methane, maybe.
The final thing I
want to say on Mars
is, did it once have an ocean?
So as I mentioned,
if you artificially
flood a map of Mars
with water, you
find that the water tends
to congregate around
the Northern hemisphere.
Now, Mars is further
from the Sun than we are,
and it's a smaller
body than we are.
So at the formation
of the solar system,
it's possible that Mars
would have cooled down
to the point where it
could have had an ocean--
liquid water on its surface--
before the Earth did.
And then it's possible that
life got started in that ocean.
And then there would
have been impacts--
and we see a lot of
impact craters on Mars--
so we know that
Martian meteorites have
been found on the Earth,
and we know that bacteria
are very stubborn things.
So is it possible the bacterial
life from the oceans of Mars
got transported to the
Earth in a meteorite,
landed on the Earth,
and then said, hmm.
It's not so bad here.
Maybe I'll evolve into us.
It's just possible
we're all martians.
Now, I suspect you were
expecting to see Jupiter next,
but I'm going to stick the
dwarf planet, as it's recently
been promoted to.
So Ceres started off its life
as a planet, when it was first
discovered in 1901.
It then got relegated
to being an asteroid.
And now it's been promoted
again to being a dwarf planet.
Now, what's interesting
about Ceres,
it's got a very dark
surface in general.
It's been exposed, as you can
see lots of impact craters.
Pretty old surface
you would think.
And then you find this rather
interesting bright feature.
Bright feature's not covered
in lots of solar system dust.
That means that bright
feature is recent,
and if you zoom in you
see potential evidence
of eruptive geysers.
Stuff is coming
out of the surface.
And this is what you get if
you get the highest resolution
images.
This is taken by the
spacecraft called
Dawn that went into orbit
around Ceres a while ago,
and I think is still operating
in orbit around Ceres.
And you can see that there is
material, very young material,
on the surface.
There are salts present there.
We think it's very briny sort
of water being squeezed out
of the surface.
But it's a real
surprise A, to find
that there's anything
fluid there at all,
and you wonder what process,
what energy source is providing
the energy to squeeze
that stuff out
of the interior of the body.
Don't know.
There are also
mountains on Ceres.
So this is the
picture looking down
on the top of a
cryovolcano, an ice volcano.
And this is what it
looks like side on.
Now, I don't know whether
you're interested in that,
but as somebody who
builds spacecraft,
I'm looking at that large
pile of ice and thinking,
that's my fuel depot for
when I want to go somewhere
else in the solar system.
It's not hard to find, is it.
There's a massive great
pile of it on the surface.
And because Ceres is a
relatively small body,
it's much easier to
get down onto Ceres
and get back off again
than it would be to go
and, say, mine the
polar caps of Mars.
So this is an exciting place
from a rocket scientist's point
of view.
Now you get Jupiter.
The quality of the images
that we're getting on Jupiter
now are immense.
The great red spot,
if you haven't heard,
for scale is bigger
than the planet Earth,
and has been
observed continuously
to be operating ever
since Jupiter was first
looked at through a
telescope by Galileo.
So we're aware that it's
a very long-lived feature.
You'll notice that the banding,
the horizontal banding,
is the sort of stuff that
occurs at moderate latitudes.
And we learnt a lot about
Jupiter from this mission.
But it's another
example of where
space exploration doesn't always
quite go the way you hope.
So this is what the spacecraft
was supposed to look like.
This is a sort of an
umbrella-like antenna that
was folded up during launch
and was supposed to unfold
a bit like an umbrella.
But it was actually like a
regular terrestrial umbrella--
they never unfold properly
when you need them to.
So some of the ribs of this
antenna got stuck here,
and it never unfolded properly.
So they had to use a
separate antenna that
was just used to
send engineering
data about the spacecraft back.
They had to use that much
smaller, much less capable
antenna to dribble all the
data back from this spacecraft.
But nevertheless,
it told us a lot.
When it arrived at
Jupiter it dropped a probe
into Jupiter's
atmosphere, detected
an awful lot of lightning.
Didn't detect much water.
But they took a
picture of Jupiter
at the point where the probe was
entering Jupiter's atmosphere.
And it dropped into
this dark region
here, which we think is a
region where, essentially, there
are no water clouds.
And so the probe didn't detect
water just because it missed.
And we think that some of these
other different colour bands
might well have had quite a
lot more water tied up in them.
Now, the spacecraft that's
in orbit around Jupiter
at the moment is called Juno.
Notice that it looks a little
different to some of the Deep
Space missions that you may
have seen in that it's got
solar panels.
This is the first
spacecraft to go beyond Mars
that's powered by solar panels.
All the Deep Space
missions that we've
done before have
had things called
radio isotope
thermal generators.
Basically, a radioactive
heat source that decays,
generates heat, and that's
turned into electricity
to power the spacecraft.
But the quality of
solar panels has
increased to the point
where you can now
go all that distance
out of Jupiter,
and go that far
away from the Sun
and still generate enough
power with solar panels.
So this mission is
deliberately designed
to go over the poles of Jupiter,
and give us a sense of what
the poles look like.
And interestingly, they're
very, very different
from the banded
structure that you
see at more moderate latitudes.
There's all sorts of cyclones
and interesting things going on
at the pole.
That mission is still running,
and expect more details
from it soon.
Moving on to Saturn, I find
this absolutely fascinating.
You see the rings, and they're
really, really impressive,
but they are only a couple of
hundred metres, top to bottom.
Thousands of kilometres side to
side, 200 metres top to bottom.
It's now thought that
as well as gravity
affecting the motion
of those particles,
that also there is
electrostatic forces.
Essentially, the particles in
the rings acquire, essentially,
a static charge
from the solar wind,
and then all the
particles want--
because they're all
at the same charge--
they want to stand at
arm's length to one another
because they're all
like charges repelling.
You get storms in the
atmosphere of Saturn
from time to time in
the summer months,
because Saturn has seasons, too.
A lot of what we've learnt about
Saturn is from this machine
called Cassini,
launched after Galileo.
And noticed that NASA changed
their strategy for antennas.
no unfurlable umbrella-like
thing this time.
Fixed dish.
Don't have to worry
about deployments
messing up your
mission on this one.
I find this picture
rather amusing.
This was a joint NASA
European mission,
but this is the American
picture of the mission.
The European contribution
is this lander
that was dropped onto the moon
Titan, and as you can see,
the Americans didn't
really sort of show it off
to the best advantage.
So one of the brilliant things
they did with this mission was
they went-- when the spacecraft
was sort of in eclipse
behind Saturn, and the Sun
was immediately behind Saturn,
they took an image looking
back towards the Sun,
and necessarily, because the
Sun is somewhere behind the disc
here, all the
interior planets are
pretty much in that direction,
from the point of view
of Saturn.
And I don't think it really
shows up on this projector,
but there are some
little bright points
which are the interior planets.
This is really weird.
So Saturn is quite
significantly out of round.
It's about 10% oblate.
So the pole to pole
distance is much less
than the equatorial radius.
But around the poles of
Saturn there is a hexagon.
Now, it's a rotating
oblate spheroid.
How do you get straight lines
on a spherical, near spherical,
rotating body?
If you know the answer to that,
please tell me because I'd
love to know.
So the Deep Space stuff has
largely been done by Voyager 2.
It's the only spacecraft that
has been to Uranus and Neptune.
Fly-bys in both cases, so brief
opportunities to collect data.
This is a more recent
ground-based image of Uranus,
showing the one bright
ring that it has around it.
It doesn't have a sort of
huge ring system like Saturn.
According to the
textbooks, that ring system
was discovered in 1977.
I've been doing some
research recently
and I think William Herschel
spotted that ring in 1789.
But that's a different lecture.
So one of the things
that Voyager discovered
is that Uranus has a really
weird magnetic field.
So on the Earth,
as you're aware,
we think the Dynamo theory
accounts for a magnetic field,
and the magnetic field has
to line up with the spin
axis of the Earth.
It's not like that on Uranus.
There is a 60 degree angle
between the magnetic axis
and the spin axis.
And the spin axis is weird.
Most of the planets
rotate with their spin
axis sort of largely pointing
up out of the orbit plane
that they're in, whereas
Uranus's spin axis is almost
in the plane of
the solar system.
Can't explain that
very well either.
It might have been hit by
something at some point,
but if so, what hit it, and
where is that thing now?
Neptune turned out to be
interesting in that Uranus was
almost a completely bland disc.
There's a lot more
weather going on Neptune.
Great dark spot, which is
a fairly transient feature,
but it's very large.
These light bits are clouds
that whistle round Neptune very
rapidly, hundreds of
kilometres an hour.
Lots and lots of activity
that we didn't see at Uranus.
But Neptune's further away
from the Sun, and it's colder,
and it should be less active.
Don't understand that either.
And finally, just
to talk a little bit
about going to Pluto.
So this is the New
Horizons mission.
It took nearly 10
years to reach Pluto.
NASA didn't want
to do this mission.
Congress mandated
it, because Pluto
was discovered by
an American, a place
called Flagstaff in Arizona.
And when the International
Astronomical Union
decided that Pluto was
going to be relegated
to the status of dwarf planet,
rather than true planet,
the people in Arizona
took exception to that.
Sorry-- it's New Mexico.
It's Flagstaff in New Mexico.
They decided that they
were going to pass a law.
And if you go out there
and you visit Flagstaff,
be aware that it is the law
there that Pluto is a planet.
No, it really is.
You ask them.
So this is what New
Horizons found on Pluto.
And again, utterly fascinating.
Lots of craters in
this sort of region,
but this bright heart
feature, as it's known,
is almost completely
devoid of craters.
There is evidence of
cryovolcanism, i.e., ice
volcanoes on Pluto, too.
Again the question,
what the hell
is providing the
energy for that?
And if you look very
closely at that smooth area,
it looks very much as if
you've got nitrogen glaciers
flowing across the surface.
Well, where's the energy coming
from to drive them around?
And if you look
really close up, you
can see it looks as if there's
some sort of slow rolling
sort of-- it's a bit like
boiling porridge or something,
if you've seen the way that
porridge behaves in a pan.
Similar sort of
thing, except this
is much colder and it's
nitrogen that's doing it.
But no impact craters at all.
A very young feature.
And this is the final picture
that New Horizons took,
as it sped away from
Pluto looking back.
And notice the
atmospheric layering here.
There's all sorts
of different species
of stuff in Pluto's atmosphere.
We're still trying to work out
what the different layers are.
But it's a sort of fitting
farewell to the solar system,
if you like.
And at that point, I'd better
stop and take some questions.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
This is a very basic
question from somebody
that knows nothing
about science.
That will make it
more embarrassing
when I can't answer it.
How do you know
that the striations
would be made by water?
And how do you
know that, you say
there's water there or
nitrogen or what rocks they are
and what chemicals,
how do you know that?
Yes.
So it's a good question.
And I have to admit that you're
repeating a question that I
asked one of my university
lecturers many moons ago.
So I said, how do
you know for sure
it was water, rather
than, say, liquid carbon
dioxide or something?
So the answer to
that question is
to do with the
pressures that were
likely to be around in
the commonness of oceans
made of water, compared to
oceans made of anything else.
At least that's
the general theory.
Although you look
at Titan, the moon
that I briefly mentioned
going around Saturn,
that's got liquid
on its surface,
but the liquid is
liquid methane.
So just as the Earth is at
the triple point of water--
so you can have ice, and
steam, and water on the surface
of the Earth--
you can have the
same three phases--
gas, solid and liquid--
of methane on Titan.
So the probability is high,
based on the chemicals that
have been found in the rocks
that have been analysed
by the rovers.
So the rovers have looked
at some of the chemicals,
and I'm not enough
of a geologist
to be able to name them for you.
But there are some chemicals
that they've essentially
dug up and looked at
on Mars that are only
formed in the presence
of water, as opposed
to carbon dioxide
or anything else.
So there's good evidence that
there was definitely water.
There might have
been other things.
I mean, there's
certainly carbon dioxide
in the atmosphere of Mars and
bound up in its polar caps.
So maybe at some point
there might have also
been carbon dioxide
liquid on the surface.
If Venus is slowing
down so quickly,
what's happening to
the angular momentum?
Well, that's what we think is
speeding up the atmosphere.
So there's an exchange of
energy between the rotation
of the planet and the
speed of the winds,
and exactly how that
works we're not clear,
because it's not a process
that we see on the Earth.
The Earth's atmosphere
is nowhere near as dense.
It's sort of like two orders
magnitude more dense on Venus.
So presumably, there's some
way of exchanging energy
between the two, but
you can't account
for the speeding up of the
winds unless you get energy
from somewhere.
And at the moment, it's
assumed that energy's
being stolen from the
rotation of the planet.
But a full explanation
is still awaited.
So what happens when it stops?
Yeah, well that's one of
the interesting things.
You can get captured rotation.
And it's possible--
you know, Mercury
is almost in captured rotation.
A weird thing about Mercury
is that a year on Mercury
is only half the length
of a day on Mercury.
So it takes Mercury 88
days to go around the Sun.
And a day from sunrise to
sunrise on Mercury is 176 days.
It's almost captured.
And it could be that Venus
will end up the same way.
Can you say how big
Ceres is, and therefore,
how big that ice mountain is,
compared to anything else?
Just over 900
kilometres in diameter.
So about 1/6 of the size
of Mars, or perhaps 1/12
the diameter of the Earth.
If the Earth is like
that, Ceres is like that.
And the mountain?
Oh, sorry.
The mountain.
I think that was on the slide.
I think it's about four
kilometres high or something
like that.
I mean, it's a
surprisingly large lump
of ice to be sat on the surface.
Could you tell me what
shape the orbit of Ceres is,
and what defines a dwarf planet?
Ah.
Right.
So the shape of the orbit is
pretty much a circle, I think.
Some of the asteroids
are more elliptical,
but I think Ceres has a
fairly circular orbit, sort
of midway sort of
between Mars and Jupiter.
If you're interested you
could look up a thing
called Bode's law, which
tries to use a rather
sort of knotty
mathematical formula
to predict the positions
of the planets.
And they used to think that
they had a gap in that law,
between Mars and Jupiter.
And then they found Ceres and
it seemed to fit the bill.
Definition of dwarf planet
is enormously controversial.
As indeed, the
definition of a planet.
This is what got the
people in the States
so steamed up when the
International Astronomical
Union decided to redefine Pluto.
So according to
the IAU, a planet
is one that has an
orbit around the Sun,
and that it's large enough
that gravity has pulled it
into a sphere.
That's what they actually wrote.
They eventually backtracked and
said hydrostatic equilibrium,
because they realised that
Saturn wasn't a sphere,
and they just ruled
out Saturn as a planet.
That was embarrassing.
And then they said
something that's
got them into an enormous amount
of trouble, which they said,
"And it has to have cleared
its orbit of other bodies."
So major planets that sort of
have no other major planets
crossing their orbits are good.
But if you have, in the case of
Ceres, lots of other asteroids
sort of crossing.
It's not necessarily the
dominant gravitational force
in its orbit, and that was used
as some really dodgy, but very
unscientific.
Because not
unreasonably you might
be sitting there thinking, what
does "cleared its orbit" mean,
and by how much?
And if you've got a moon
going around your planet,
sometimes that moon's
going to cross your orbit.
Have you cleared your orbit?
Embarrassingly, Jupiter
has two large groups
of asteroids that are 60
degrees ahead of Jupiter
and 60 degrees behind it,
called the Trojan asteroids.
They're there for
gravitational reasons.
They will be for the
lifetime of the solar system,
as far as we know.
So Jupiter hasn't
cleared its orbit
because it's got loads and loads
of asteroids sharing its orbit
for gravitational reasons.
But the IAU seemed to
have overlooked that fact.
So Jupiter's not a planet
either by that definition.
It's a really
rubbish definition,
and I can't offer you a
better one, I'm afraid.
Well, thanks so much.
I'm really sorry, but we are
overrunning very slightly.
Stuart, are you going
to be hanging around
for the tea break?
Yeah, absolutely.
So if you want questions
later, I'm happy to help.
Please do see the man in
the astronomical waistcoat.
But for the time
being, can we say
thank you very much
to Stuart Eves.